hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to let's play and knees
you a machine for pigs okay in the last
part we may have set in motion the end
of the world somehow because this
machine was actually leading me to start
it which in my opinion I totally knew
that starting the machine was a bad idea
but that's just me I'm not in control
here apparently I'm I'm just at the whim
of this psycho crazy bonkers guy in sure
conduits a corrected place to avoid
pressure back draft child fatalities
this month 17 oh boy that's a lot of
fatalities so what am I doing here
I don't even know I'm trying to get to
somewhere that I can stop this is crazy
machine but I'm not sure what I'm doing
seems like the piggy piggies might be
helping me a bit okay so I got to get
through to there but to get to there I
need to stop the pressure flow or
something I don't really know hello
steam vent access only at low pressure
okay so if in the throws of my evil I
sent children into the pipes to clean
them then it seems likely there's
another entrance I can use to escape
this noxious maelstrom of engines I will
ignore the burning in my nostrils from
the fumes of that godless compound X
that fuels these machines and I will
become the saboteur I will destroy the
pressure system enabling the me to enter
the pipes without fear so I fixed
everything just to be able to destroy
him all over again
that seems like an efficient process
okay so yeah I'll break all your set
okay now that we're done breaking
everything not yet
we got one more whoo
but no okay so now I should be able to
get up there no there's still one more
press to do daddy somewhere but where
where where is it wait I can get through
here now it still seems to be pressure
but that's not a good sign
this cogwheels here is there someplace
that I can put these cog wheels that it
would matter and put it into it no okay
I got a journal note let's see some form
of steam regulator I'll wager if I I'll
wager if I disable it the damage caused
by the rushing steam pressure could be
catastrophic certainly enough to force a
temporary stalling of this entire engine
that should cause the steam pressure to
drop mandus you clever old gag goat I
can feel this horror this grief this
betrayal boil in a fury I will not stand
I will not be under trodden if this
machine is my heirloom I am the over man
wait
see see boss some of the clearly visible
if I reroute the steam I can wreak havoc
first clumsy attempt it's sabotage so
how did I get persuaded to do it again
that is the question how did I get
persuaded to fix all this [ __ ] I mean
obviously I was going after my children
but I mean come on man
you don't remember a ding dong damn
thing okay
everything seems to be a shaken man a
shimmying so I've got to be able to
reroute the flow somehow I need to find
something that's gonna allow me to do it
maybe if I take this pipe I'll be able
to somehow get it into those pipes in
there and then be able to do something
with it I don't know I don't know what
I'm doing I'm kinda just flailing around
trying to find an option but I don't
know there's yellow tape on this is
yellow tape on that maybe it's a maybe
it's a match born in Avenue oh no oh no
it's not okay I need to be able to find
a way to sabotage this automatic steam
regulator but how that is the question
Oh
maybe just oh you gotta be oh really
let's just poke at it a bit until it
blows up with my bare hands nothing can
stop my bare hands Oh
Oh piggy piggy piggy piggy piggy okay
sorry piggy where did you come from
sorry piggy piggy I don't have time for
you oh okay now that closed up dad
journal stop calmly everybody calm down
now quickly through the pipes Oh quickly
through the pipes I'll return to the
streets fetch help and lead people upon
the factory burn it to the ground and
seal this place on the ground forever if
you say so ma'am if you say so
once again I don't know if you will be
able to accomplish with juice whoa what
happened what happened
it seemed to hurt oh I'm in or I'm in a
hurry I forgot kind of rushing need to
hurry the F up get it go go go go right
there's no one does to save if you say
so
hey piggies how about you don't kill
them and by them I mean me and by them I
mean there's only one of me
anything to save them of course all the
awful we cannot sell from our system is
donated to the workhouse making them
perhaps the best fattened unfortunates
in the whole of London well good for
them isn't that just phenomenal I still
don't know what this machine does or why
it exists there's still a mystery to
solve
just saying Tom saying don't know what's
going on still don't know what's going
on okay back in the elevator again going
up
lalalalala just waiting along nothing to
see totally relaxed oh oh no what is
happening in here
Oh No is there a piggy piggy over there
little piggy no no little piggy go home
wait a minute shout outside my outside
is that what's happening
am i actually outside did I die I didn't
think it'd be that easy okay let's go
cuz apparently this whole place is gonna
blow up
no Hawking no bragging no soliciting oh
that's what you meant by them
I know know what after you done man
I think the piggies are killing the
whole town which is bad okay
there's a pathless there's a dead man
over there
good all that shit's grass
[Music]
how why how how are you doing this to
just a machine oh this doesn't seem good
what the hell is going on here this
doesn't make any sense no one misses the
poor round up some orphans in the world
will thank you for it disappear a [ __ ]
and a gentleman applause you call a
beggar and a lady walk safely again I
hate them I hate them more than any of
the others this privilege this
pretension these so-called leaders these
pillars of society these rich and
fanciful they wear their filth on the
inside but they are no less dirty I have
plans for them all we will feed them and
then we will feed from them okay what
does that mean I don't think I was
supposed to come up here for this sake
of progression try just another thing to
find down here know what am i oh I get
it okay okay I'm gonna assume that the
piggies are too busy devouring the rest
of the town to bother me Berner Street I
thought that's a Bieber Street
okay
well alright then you crazy bastard well
I've actually seen other people saw them
dying but whatever God forgive me what
if I Unleashed I stand and smell the
burning City I see a ship on the wind I
hear the roars of the sickening beasts
and the screams as they fall upon the
city and drag its people below for this
slaughter now I begin to understand what
the other composite ingredient of
compound X must be and I also understand
it is my responsibility now I must find
way back to the heart of the machine and
complete what I started okay I probably
go back down there but let me just
explore the city a bit more okay alright
there's nothing to explore there's
nothing left wait a minute what the hell
is that my kitties why were they doing
that okay I get it I'm going back I'm
going down so all of London is dying for
what I have done
Oh oh hi oh you're in there you're
actually there you're actually here
oh boy hello note i standed look at
myself in the mirror penis in hand and
my reflection grins at me and my mouth
is full of cell foam sulfur mustards
vain fool are you really so very
different do you genuinely believe your
works of evil are any greater than the
rest of them you are simply a weak man a
product of his age the same as any other
this Empire [ __ ] this is a killing
idiocy the natural result of this social
Darwinism if you are evil then this
world is evil you just let the blood run
in the street rather than hiding it in
the poorhouse you hold the blade and
slide at home yourself you do not pay a
man to do this for you where you cannot
see it if you are evil at least yours is
an honest evil and that alone makes you
Boober mensch and thus I wash my hands
and take my bed what who what like so
much of this game it's just so much what
so much what why can I move this box
I missed moving boxes okay wait I'm just
going in a circle I don't need to go
this way I need to go up those stairs
I'm so lost so lost so lost so lost oh
boy no boy back into the machine it's my
favorite place to be everyone stops
screaming now I'm assuming they're all
dead which is totally good
back in the city right right okay so why
does it sound like this fireworks go my
seriously why does it sound like they're
fireworks and what the hell is that
thing in the distance over there it's
gigantic
okay
once again what the hell are you doing
over there
why are you doing what are you doing
are you eating are you doing something
way different I don't know I don't I
don't think I want to know I don't buy
me okay
I can't move
there we go I guess that did it
good job me what the hell yeah yeah go
run off over there bother someone else
with your stupidity there are too many
of these damn nations these beasts loose
on the street too all have come from the
engine rooms as I emerged I counted
three of the damnable pneumatic lifts
would suggest the machine has been
planning this for some time
smuggling routes to the surface all
about this neighborhood if my bearings
are correct beyond the alley I should
stand directly over the ignition room
and I will wager that if I find a
pneumatic there it will carry me back to
the machine's heart I do have some
complaints about this whole situation
but I'll save my comments until I reach
the end there dad dude don't don't you
know don't you know man
oh look it's another pig mask okay seems
like I'm finally going back down I I
guess cool heard that
okay I have to say something about this
right now
farming the world the missing vein I see
this now we must find them those Scrolls
those old words written upon metal rods
that glow in the half-light have light
the dusk this gloaming okay I have to
say something this whole sequence is
about as subtle as a wrench to the face
and wasn't very scary you know no I mean
not I mean it's not really what I was
expecting from amnesia so I'm kind of
confused as to what's going on this
whole direction is taken is very strange
and way overly bombastic from what I
would have expected from it it's not
particularly horrifying you know when I
see all these pigs running around that
are of no threat to me
and I know they're not a threat to me
because they don't even come for me
except for that last one and I almost
got away from that one it was slightly
scary in the beginning but I don't know
I'm just utterly confused as to what's
going on I still don't know what this
frickin machine's supposed to do I mean
when I was playing amnesia was a slow
steady unveiling of what the hell is
going on and then all of a sudden boom
the world is ending
oh hello what's going on through here I
Roush oh they're gathering up more
bodies for this machine to feed the
machine to do something so that's the
master plan I get it I think I get it
you're collecting people so that you can
do whatever it is you meant to do in the
first place
oh really should I go to there really
okay no
yeah I get a bit you're trying to
collect as many things for whatever
you're trying to do but I mean
something's going on no machine blades
for fatty Bishop and gluttony Harris
prime cuts all for the sorting bins and
the very best as always back in the
dumbwaiter to the kitchen above to be
stewed and plumped and gravy din bread
Camden returned to the table for the
next night's feast and not every night
you see although we have begun to
increase the frequency of the final act
unlike the poor the rich will be missed
given time but we will continue to spoil
and ready them and our fine foods are
now exported to mansions and lodges
across London and it has been noted in
the times of late how rather overweight
the Great and the good are becoming with
their diets of fine wine and rich meat
indeed in pinch in punch just last week
a carton showed Viscount sulla Wordle
shaluinn as a stuffed pig laid upon a
platter for his peers to dine upon a
vicious and cowardly slander no doubts
but he tasted delicious okay so in the
first amnesia they were extracting vit a
from the people because Alexander just
wanted to go home but this seems like
something on an astronomically other
scale but anyway I'm gonna reserve a lot
of my comments til the end of the game
because obviously I have not reached the
end so I don't know where this is all
going towards but for now I gotta say
that was a little or that was a lot not
scary though I gotta say for now so
anyway thank you all so much for
watching click the annotation for more
videos and I've done and as always I
will see you in the next video
[Music]
[Applause]